from elsewhere and she's coming do you
think she actually respects you can we
ask the girl maybe i'm actually curious
to get your take on this if you're
dating a guy let's just say we're not me
personally we're dating a guy this is
baby i love you you're everything i ever
wanted in a girl you're perfect your
body your smile the way you treat me
everything about you is perfect but if
you want to go out and [ __ ] other guys
i'm totally cool with it
so it's how would you take that this
this is an interesting question i'm
actually okay with with your belief
system it's like teach their own it's
not the norm yeah so it's probably weird
to hear but if you know teach their own
everyone have their own beliefs about oh
so we talking about me personally
i mean it's a bit cuckold yeah
you can you you can you can just you can
describe to whatever yeah i'm curious
what you're gonna say go ahead uh it's
an interesting question to ask me right
now um i
i've always really valued the idea of
monogamy um and when i was like 19 i
fell in love with someone
and it was not a healthy relationship
was pretty toxic but i really loved the
idea that we were each other's person so
i really believe in that i believe that
i have a person out there who
i'm gonna be a team with right and i
believe in the masculine and the
feminine dynamic right i do believe in
that um i've considered the idea of
polyamory before right um just based on
the fact that when i met this person i
thought i would never connect to anyone
as deeply as i could connect to him
right right and that was more
spiritually emotionally that sort of
thing um and since then i've met a lot
of people that i've connected
emotionally and spiritually to and it's
not always been sexual sometimes that's
just friendships and that sort of thing
but i realize that the depth of
connection i can have with people isn't
really limited to one person i still
have an idea that i believe i have my
person
um
but
i i think i could entertain the idea of
an open relationship
um would you prefer it
i i this is where i'm at right now i
actually don't know you don't know it's
i don't know it's still something i'm
trying to figure out because i do like i
said i i value the idea of um like i
want a family i want to have you know i
want to be a mom i want to have a kid i
want to have a very strong family
dynamic that's kind of something i see
for myself um
um
and i don't know if an open relationship
would necessarily be conducive to that
based based on what society kind of says
right but i also believe that a child
can be raised in a happy environment
regardless of the parameters of the
relationships
as long as they're loved forget what
society says i think if you meet a man
yeah right
and he loves you and you love him
he's going to not generally generally
he's not going to want to let you you're
not going to want to loan your vagina
out yeah and this is why i don't know if
i'm polyamorous because because i don't
like the idea of someone with i'm with
sleeping with other people i'd want to
be
that you know we choose each other right
and we commit to each other and then we
would grow and build whatever from there
um i i kind of like the this is i don't
know if this is getting tmi but i like
the idea of bringing someone else into
the relationship but i think
can the mother of your child loan her
vagina at somebody
i don't have any children but i would
predict no for me guys absolutely not
no chance
what do you mean learn your vagina out
it's not a [ __ ] transaction amazing
what if she gets broken
what if she gets pregnant
unique individual
like this you are a unique individual
yeah i love it
but i'm just saying like
would you be okay with the mother of
your child
in a polyamorous relationship with you
yes what if she gets pregnant with
another man's child yeah that's a good
question if she
if she has consented like then like
would you raise the child
i was raised by a step father so you
would raise the child yes i was i i was
like my the the the [ __ ] the man the
male that raised me my alpha
was not my biological father
so so what what so what's that society
needs that society does need you know
men to raise women's kids in certain
circumstances
yeah and and this is this so one i saw
something like i think it was a post or
something about a lawyer who was like a
divorce lawyer and he was saying to this
couple that you know what if my kids
have to grow up with you know two sets
of parents and they said well a kid can
never have enough people to love them
right there's always more people that
can love a child and help them grow
right kids are raised by a village right
and the more people that love them but
they do need it biologically but the
problem isn't necessarily not
necessarily they need a strong masculine
figure yes and that can manifest in
different ways i will say that one
problem is that like the
i can't remember the stat off the top of
my head i'd look it up but my laptop
died they took it
but it's like the
when somebody is a single parent the
most likely person that is going to
sexually abuse them is someone they
bring into the house in a relationship
and so you're putting your kid at risk
and i know everyone thinks i know
everyone thinks like oh it wouldn't
happen to me like i would vet them
better but you just never know everybody
and that's all right so then so then i
would bring it back to saying that's
probably the exception and that's the
biggest obstacle
in terms of that context because i and i
think if we go back to like probably
vetting someone and probably making
proper choices right you have to
consider the kids right and that's
that's that's you know if you do that
then you're probably not
i agree with you i i do think it's the
exception not the rule i don't think
that every single step parent is abusing
the child but the point the but the
point is you're still putting that kid
at risk for abuse you're putting them at
risk they're more likely to run away
from home they're more likely to
um to be on the streets yeah to be on
drug like it's like every every student
mental health issues every statistical
advantage that you could put a kid at
you're putting them at in a single
parent home right and to be in jail
all it's just it's statistics
you can laugh and you can
concentrate
and even even and even
they are and you can quantify all your
supports as much as you like but you're
still just throwing random numbers that
don't actually happen okay okay
i can't even tell you like just
anecdotally and like
so just from talking to people day to
day like i i have nine siblings same two
parents we adopted three and
like when i talk to people that come
from single parent homes about like my
family's traditions every year like i've
never seen like such like like they want
that so bad it's really sad like they've
never experienced like
no sorry sorry
i'm laughing at something else um
no it's it's sad though like they've
never experienced like christmas with
both parents together like and then all
the traditions we do like we do pictures
with santa every year we do like an
easter egg huh like like family's really
big and
i
i just see like the loss that someone's
at when they didn't get to grow up with
two parents and i just wouldn't wish
that upon anyone but i think i think
again that comes down to two parents yes
but also having adults that love you
right and adults that are a team that
can raise you right because that's a big
family and you have traditions but you
can have traditions and lots of
different family dynamics right in a
polyamorous room right when a team comes
together to raise a kid you can still
build traditions it's just a bit of a
different dynamic but i think i think
it's better like we kind of did have a a
team raise us because like we had we had
help and we also had like relatives that
stepped in my grandma's like i could
name you a long list of people that
helped and stepped in but i think it's
better when it's like in the family
and it's all what's the difference
between a community that you build in a
community that's biological like what's
happening
i would say i would say
it's it's like more vetted and so like
you're because you're going around
people that have known each other for
years for years like and
more vetted
because family members are um nobody
family members are they they can
be that person who sexually abuses you
know it is possible for that to happen
right that's not not gonna happen you're
correct but
i would say that it's easier to like i
put it
like everyone knows who the weird uncle
is
everyone everybody knows exactly
everyone knows who the weird uncle is in
the family and you keep your kids away
from the weird uncle
and i'm not saying it doesn't happen but
i
just anecdotically would guess that it
happens at a much lower rate when it's
family than when it's
random people that you've met i don't
know if you'd be able to can i just say
because i want to go back to what's
something that you said
because i said that
children need two biological parents and
you said that they don't yeah right
how do you reconcile
that a child who was born of two people
doesn't need those two people
how do you reconcile like how how do you
say they don't need that have you been
if that's if that's how they came into
the world
so so my entire existence i was raised
by someone who wasn't my biological
parent and he's my father
and he's wonderful were you raised but
was your mother there your biological
mother was my biological mother was
there yes
and i was raised by
as many of you know i was just banned on
tick tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible